like let me start with the poll question
lawyers good or bad for basketball great
for basketball and great I mean the NBA
is not the NFL this is not parody Pete's
League it's a league built by the
dynastic Celtics if the leak is known
for dynasties that's like so we're bill
Russell's Celtics bad for the NBA where
Michael Jordan's Bulls bad for the NBA
were the Lakers that got to the finals
nine times in 12 years in the in MAGIX
time were they bad for the NBA of course
not this to me this is not even
difficult the Warriors are great for the
NBA because that's what people will turn
they turn into sea stars and great teams
they're not they're not looking for
upsets is not March Madness
and so they're great for the NBA I'm
also looking at tonight in particular
and let's say you have no rooting
interest but you're looking at this
purely from basketball and storylines
are you rooting for a sweep or are you
rooting for the Cavs to win this game I
just think it's entirely dependent on
who you like you know and for people
that a lot younger than us Dan if it
depends on you know the social media
issues or what shoes they're where I'm
it's like you know taking a NASCAR
driver what do you identify I think it's
entirely dependent on that or whether
they think the Warriors are villainous
because of the way Durant joined them I
mean people have all their personal
reasons so I you know I don't think
there's any sort of universal standard
for why anybody's rooting for anybody
I'm sort of rooting for the series to
continue just to justify my absurd
position apparently that dad that this
couldn't happen dance when people were
suggesting five games I was like hey
listen LeBron with no Kyrie and no Kevin
Love took the Warriors six games two
years ago don't tell me this is not
going six or seven and obviously you
know I was really wrong and the people
like Jeff Van Gundy who said five games
if that were a lot smarter about
anticipating what would happen during
this series so I'm sort of rooting for
it to go a little bit but I'd love
seeing greatness
I mean that's the thing I appreciate
about the in being somebody is great and
you can't stop them I want to see them
over and over again I want to see the
sweep because then we're seeing
something we've never seen before
15 oh yeah yeah and it also gives us
storylines to talk about we'll talk
about this forever because it's amazing
how like people are surprised I guess
that magic says his Lakers could be
Golden State dr. J 76ers could beat them
I want to know the guy who says you know
what my team would have no chance
against Golden State
I'm waiting for one of these Hall of
Fame players to say like Bill Laimbeer
to say you know what
bad boys couldn't be then wake me up
when that happens because everybody is
so territorial and prideful they think
they could be Golden State but I'm
looking for the sweet because it's
historical and it gives us something
different than we've ever had and that
is that's perfectly a great thing as
well to root for um by the way I mean I
think there look you you seen the
balance of this league over the years we
both have I mean I think there are six
or eight teams
I don't mean group of teams you know
like people try to play well the the
Pistons you know of three years none of
that you got to pick one season team to
to compare and I think there's six or
five or six teams that will be in the
discussion maybe maybe more than that
maybe six or seven teams that would be
in the discussion whose players ought to
think that whose all of the same players
ought to think no we could we could take
them now not every championship team you
know there's some teams I wouldn't want
to hear from but I'll tell you what the
76ers of 1983 that's one of the team's
that's the fo fo-fo team yeah it slipped
up and lost the game - what Milwaukee
that's one of the teams where I think
about it I'm like you know you know
anybody anybody who ever played the game
we have trouble against that team so I
you're right 60 L gives you all those
sorts of themes to talk about
comparisons to make and just endless
endless material these Michael Wilbon
from pardon the interruption also
working on the road for Sports Center
covering the NBA Finals can you
member and athlete as scrutinized as
LeBron James yeah Tiger Woods yeah I'm
more so in some ways Michael Jordan yeah
but but not but not Tigers playing
ability he got scrutinized as a person
and he was pre social media
LeBron is scrutinized for his playing
and only one thing off the court really
well two things the decision and then
you know what happened recently in Los
Angeles but other than that it's been
about scrutinizing him in the film or
porn
I mean LeBrons bein almost
letter-perfect off the off the court I
mean I you know for me but he's been so
nice more than any other and you mean it
totally his plight well he doesn't want
to take the big shot you know he's from
it there remember when before the seven
years in Jordan couldn't win yeah and no
good if we had social media of course
not but we didn't kill him then because
the Celtics and Lakers were so good and
the Pistons that well he was a ball hog
and he was a guy was a scorer could
never win I mean I think I think we tend
to forget the ha wasn't the best player
in the game at the time it was still
magic and Larry who were sharing that
yeah I guess it was more like three or
four years of it there wasn't 13 or 14
years of it it's a lot it's a lot I'm
trying to think if there's a baseball
player maybe not I mean a run across
area a Ron a lot you know but your point
I'm not dismissing I'm not disagreeing
I'm just thinking through the other
people I mean you raise a great point
about about LeBron and you know I
thought the other night when he made
that pass we're going to start hearing
where's Donyell Marshall when do we get
to that we're going to start hearing
about Danielle and you know it was
interesting because I watched the game
with I watch the game with Paul Pierce
Jalen Rose and Chauncey Billups and PJ
some of it able to hear people who made
a living playing and coaching basketball
I mean you're right the dissection is
just tremendous like I had so it is one
of the enjoyable nights of my
professional life watching that game
with them any of the various opinions
and the things that come up
actions possession you know I the text I
was getting from from Hall of Fame
players to him you know why can't LeBron
understand that if he goes into the post
he can rest and still be in the game and
still dominate the game from the post
position why would he do that
and I asked PJ that on the air PJ why
won't the bran do it because you know I
had dinner last night with Charles
Barkley
that's it Chuck so when you were tired
and you're planning is Shawn Kemp
alright you know pick somebody but that
was a conference finally at one point
are you playing his calm alone what what
did you do if you didn't want to come
out of the game and Charles goes you go
into the post well Jordan did that to
Jordan yeah of course and so why so as
we talk about the scrutiny of LeBron
James game why won't he do it but
remember when this series started and
everybody said all you know Cleveland
can match him they can shoot threes and
I went you do not want to go temple for
temple again don't you don't don't and
if I've got something that is different
than you guys can defend I I have to
melee you that yeah I have to make
Golden State uncomfortable at some point
and they haven't been uncomfortable and
it's too late now but I agree with you
it you know you're going to play into
their hands if you think you can be out
perimeter Golden State you can dunk a
student what so you know that if you
have post game and LeBron is the best
player added today because nobody does
it it you get you're going to force a
double-team which means somebody is
going to be open maybe one of those
shooters you got other shooters on the
floor you you're going to compromise
perhaps your defense you're going to get
somebody in foul trouble but you know
what Dan these are ancient concepts you
know they don't play that waiting where
it's all pick-and-roll it's all spread
the floor it's all shoot two three you
don't want to ask Chris Webber first
down or he said what what does Cleveland
need and he said Talent it's an
understand their great and okay does
Cleveland do something dredge drastic in
the offseason yeah I think they will
because because if they don't you know
is that the most well I think they will
first of all I think if they don't then
they lose LeBron next year
they may lose him anyway you think he's
gone I don't think he ends his career in
Cleveland well then then then we're
talking about now I mean it's year 15
would you would you trade would you
entertain trading LeBron James no I
would trade I was I would trade Kyrie
Irving I speak on the phone with the
Clippers and Chris Paul's agent saying
why don't we sign and train what do we
need to do here that we can the Clippers
would have to do that damn because they
ain't no way can you get the fire going
under will bond because Skip Bayless
just called and said damn that's a hot
take that will bond just had give me
some fire under there Paulie
what's so Kyrie Irving to the Clippers
and Gators Paul with LeBron yeah because
that way you keep Chris part you keep
LeBron in Cleveland it is part of his
buddies here mmm
Biggie and Chris Paul look Chris Paul is
entertaining the clip the San Antonio
Spurs then Cleveland needs to get
involved with that and say wait a minute
we got a better opportunity to you Chris
Paul is not going to get to the finals
with the Clippers unless LeBron goes
there and maybe that's possible but as a
free agent I could see that happening
before me too I could see that happening
but then we don't so we talking one more
year here yeah so that means they have
this on the traffic and that means these
are trading Kevin law or Kyrie Irving or
both well you're not going to get as
much for Kevin Love as you would for
Kyrie Irving right that's right I could
totally agree so so you you you need to
do something this summer or you did you
get the LeBron James discussion again
next summer and I don't think they just
let a lock maybe they do maybe you know
maybe maybe they they're not going to
get a championship this year next so
they get one out of it
one that's one they had in 50 years for
Cleveland but you know no I I think they
have to get creative and daring and
realize that you know they got just the
window you know while a bronze window
may stay open you know three or four
more years or winning a championship
wherever he's wherever he is I don't
think that necessarily means Cleveland's
window remains open I don't think you
have more than one more game left in
your voice Mike so you better hope first
which is what happens you know do you
know about this dinner with Charles you
wind up screaming about stuff and you
might have had a beverage or two no you
know in the couple
you dummy you know that a beverage guy
huh somebody somebody drink my red wine
what it wasn't me of course it wasn't no
of course it wasn't Mike great to talk
to you again safe travels there and
thanks for joining us all right Dan
thanks man I appreciate it that's
Michael Wilbon Wilbon the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience